at the end of this video i will be
ranking every jojo i've read about and
every jojo op
i've listened to in one big tier list
but before i get into that it's time to
round off this series with the
completion of part five
bringing me up to date with the official
localization available to
english speakers around the world and
this arc's ending
surprised me to put it simply but i want
to dive into that in more detail later
the overall story in this part 5 had me
laughing singing it on the edge of my
seat throughout its
duration and today i'm going to break it
down and give you my tier list for
jojo's bizarre adventure but first here
are my final thoughts on a series i've
grown to love and respect
over the last two months with you all
i'm totally not mark and these are my
first impressions of thoughts on and
review for
the fabled second half of jojo's fifth
part
golden width
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so as i said at the beginning this
one was a very
strange experience and i mean that in
the good bizarre way that i've become
accustomed to but
also in that other slightly more
negative way but generally speaking
95 of this arc is my favorite bit of
jojo and
the other 5 is probably the most
underwhelming piece of jojo that i've
ever seen and just so happens that 5
occupies the last few episodes but i'll
get to that
a little later because most of this
second half i absolutely adored forcing
me to take back all of my prior
criticisms in the first half
while also continuing to deliver what
made the first half of the story so
infectious and engaging
delivering terrific fights left right
and center
bite your tongue naranja this might very
well be the most interesting and
creative fight scene in the second half
meaning we are starting off strong with
a naranja fight
taking place right after fugo pieces out
literally never to be seen again for the
rest of this story i'm serious
we get a lead from trish pointing the
finger to sardinia where there may be a
lead
that points to the boss's true identity
there they encounter this amazing team
of stand users one that has a small fish
that attacks people
and another that has a small stand that
forces the host to say the opposite of
what they mean
it's such a fun and bizarre what-if
scenario that i couldn't see
being made into a reality in any other
story by far
this is the arc's strongest aspect i
think with this one in particular
forcing the hero team to work together
as journal fashions a new tongue for
laurentia to out the bad guys in the act
the very best fights in this arc are
really this series come from when more
than one person works together
apart from this feeling narratively
satisfying watching two friends battle
together this arc employs so much
thought and creativity behind
each outing's respective execution that
i'd be surprised if araki said this
wasn't his favorite aspect of writing
jojo and as for the bad guys
they all get brutally murdered fight on
a plane
in addition to all of these terrific and
thoughtful fights this second half
fulfills my one request in giving trish
something more to work with in terms of
character
thanks to this fight on the plane
wherein she develops and comes to grips
with her very own
stand however that visual and mechanical
aspect to the story is not
why i like it necessarily instead i like
it for what it does for trisha's
character
taking a closer look it's important to
recognize the choices different
characters make in a story this very
aspect is key to helping the audience
build a bond and for us to
well like them it makes us want them to
succeed for instance the lion king has a
scene in the elephant graveyard where
simba saves
nala from the hyenas this is key because
up until this point simba has been a
childish brat
but in that moment we realized that
while he blusters a lot he also stands
behind what he says
helping us grow to like simba as a
character and they cut it out of the
live-action remake
okay american chill uh wrong video
another time after a fleshing parasite
type stand find this way onto the plane
it becomes a very real threat that
forces trish to either run
hide or fight very early it's made
obvious that she doesn't want anything
to do with it and
it is in fact terrifying to her however
what keeps her from staying put in
hiding
is her desire to prevent it from causing
further harm to her team
in essence she forces herself out of a
more comfortable situation
for the sake of others in other words
she becomes a hero and i love that
the boss oddly enough my favorite aspect
of this arc second half comes from one
of my larger criticisms within the first
diavolo the big boss man behind this
nationwide criminal syndicate
having been established as being
hell-bent on protecting his most prized
possession his true identity one of
iraqi's biggest strengths is his
fearless exploration into an idea and
never doing anything
by any half measures because of this
philosophy he created something in
diavolo
i never anticipated or saw coming the
psychotic unsettling and creative
depiction of a man with a split
personality sharing the same body with a
younger more fragile personality
receiving calls and instructions from
the boss through his own delusion
demonstrating to us
through his backstory and his ultimate
conflict with risotto after his team had
been almost completely taken out by
bruno's crew like kira there's a
sprinkling of vulnerability to diavolo's
depiction
particularly during this section as he
desperately gives direction to his
younger subordinate in creepier and
creepier ways
however it should be noted that diavolo
unlike kira strikes a much more imposing
tone and for the most part poses a much
more interesting threat to the crew
rather than simply running he pursues
the crew feeding him in nail-bitingly
exciting scenarios
as we watch him indirectly and directly
figure out how to solve his situations
respectively with all of his established
characteristics later paying off
or making for some really interesting
situations thanks to his unique
character design both physically and
mentally speaking just about managing to
escape this particular occasion with
risotto
though not without sustaining a
considerable amount of damage all the
while another member of bruno's team
bites the dust moments before he reveals
what he looks like to the crew
dying in the line of duty he'll be
missed green day and oasis
again this is another example of a team
of villains who stands complement each
other
one creates mold on your body the lower
you go and the other turns the ground
into mush they complement each other and
the relationship is
fine who might the judge it comes to
giorno's tension that bruno isn't okay
that he keeps sustaining weird amounts
of damage but not saying anything about
how he got it
and as it turns out he's actually sort
of
dead and giorno's gold experience
back on the island off of venice healed
him enough to keep going a bit longer in
truth
he's dead but not dead dead and if that
sounds confusing then
you know exactly as much as i do after
being contacted by a mysterious
individual who claims to have answers
the team now need to get past these guys
and meet this individual at the coliseum
in rome the perfect place to end our
stint in italy
once again the action is spectacular
with the stakes at times feeling
enormous
with guest appearances even by diavolo
and giorno gets to do something which i
am always a fan of and what's more is
bruno is a boss and takes out the weird
muddy water swimming guy once we get to
the coliseum however we get to meet
paulereth and he becomes a tortoise
which
is cool okay so there's a bit of
explaining that involves some of the
things in this finale that i'm not sure
i
liked but let me say one last nice thing
when everyone swaps bodies and yeah okay
that happens they swap bodies that's how
polymorph ends up in the tortoise i
really liked that you could tell which
personality was in which body
just by looking at the posing of the
respective characters that was a really
cool visual touch
and okay it's time to discuss the ending
now the ending
those among you that have taken the time
to watch any of my other reviews will
notice that when something impresses me
i
tend to be more critical of it that
shouldn't be taken as any indication
other than respect
when a story surprises me i like to up
my default standard to test where the
merits of the story truly lie
for instance i'm not going to heavily
scrutinize over the idiosyncrasies of
phantom blood's narrative because
it's a simple story exercising quite
well and established formula while
adding in some interesting things here
and there
and in the case of stardust crusaders
it's clear what araki was going for and
when the ending came about it fit that
building quite well
in other words trying to get a read on
what the ark is trying to do is key in
determining for me if it's successful or
not in its execution but when it comes
to stories like
golden wind i think there's enough going
on under the surface to warrant holding
the expertise of a rocky to a higher
standard and keeping that in mind
because
of this i have to say that i thought the
ending to golden wind in addition to
being disappointing
on a narrative level personally also
felt confused
convenient and felt as though it
struggled to tie anything together
and as a result made other earlier
choices in the story feel either
tagged in or totally undelivered upon
but i want to make one thing clear
this isn't the same thing as a show
delivering something good with it not
being what i particularly liked
or being let down by comparison i mean i
never would have expected part four to
go the way that it went
and typically if stories stick the
landing i end up enjoying those stories
a lot more because they surprised me so
let's dive into my specific issues with
golden wind's
conclusion it doesn't feel like it
delivers upon the promise it makes at
the beginning of the story
this might be a somewhat abstract
concept to understand but
in truth most every story promises
something at the beginning in some shape
or form the promise is that whatever is
said
or shown will be important to the story
moving forward in big or small ways that
everything we are being shown has
meaning that there's purpose behind it
however this isn't or at least didn't
feel like the case when it comes to
golden wind some of my favorite pieces
of writing towards the beginning came
from ho koichi and jonaro
became a part of the story and how they
engaged with journal's life
but once they show up they disappear
never to be seen from again so i ask
what was the point of them
even being there in the first place
because it's tradition to have old
characters take part
and what about fugo why give that
character so much development if he
isn't going to add
anything meaningful to the ark these two
things were in the back of my mind
knocking around
all throughout the climax of the story i
was waiting for them i
liked fugo i liked the idea behind the
motivation for koichi in this story
but none of these were delivered upon
despite them contributing a large amount
to the story and this just left me
wondering why they were there at
all if they offered little to nothing
for the second half of the story the
fight scenes during this section felt
spectacular they were well animated and
visually stunning i mean requiem gold
experience
looks awesome but and this is a big but
for me
it's style over substance and that
substance is
missing from the story what makes great
endings great in my book
is in part visual spectacle which can
take many different forms but it's
also how the story manages to tie back
into the beginning or an earlier part of
the story to help
grant a greater sense of occasion
gravity or
meaning to the conflict at hand i like
to think back to series like one piece
or even dragon ball
one piece is filled to bursting with
conclusions tying themselves back to the
beginning or an earlier part of the arc
to better inform its conclusion
think of the going mary saving everyone
from any's lobby or
think the giant shadow and fight with a
nel in skypia and think of the battle
that luffy had with katakuri that was
perfectly informed by the ark in
question and kanakuri's relationship
with his family this tells us something
about the world it tells us something
about why they're fighting and it tells
us something about the characters
none of this is random and it makes the
conclusion all the more satisfying
because of it it feels more real
similarly when it came to gohan
transforming during his fight with cell
we knew and felt that this was a
monumental moment because
it like everything else i've mentioned
was built up to
and when it happened it did so with
great occasion and fanfare much to the
delight of
everyone watching but when requiem gold
experience took out diavolo
the boss of the massive criminal
syndicate i felt like i watched an
ending that was put together by someone
that hadn't read or known anything about
the prior events of the story
because it didn't really tie anything
together granted i appreciate that the
bow and arrow stuff has been part of the
story since part four
but the elements that this arrow
contributes to the story have nothing to
do with anything we've learned about it
before other than what the arrow looks
like
the concept of piercing your own stand
isn't introduced until the third
act of this arc which is all in service
of ending this arc the way araki wanted
to but if he wanted to
why not make that aspect part of the
beginning the way iraqi wanted to end
this arc is by granting gold experience
not giorno
gold experience a power-up that gives
the stand agency and a brand new ability
that perfectly fits the situation to
take out diavolo
it has nothing to do with journal
nothing to do with what jorno has
learned or achieved throughout this
journey feels as though it's contributed
in any meaningful way towards this
ending and as a result
i feel like a new random character in
requiem gold experience just shows up
with a brand new convenient power
to save the day this more than anything
made the ending fall flat for me
causing me to wonder where the tension
went and what was the point of this
entire journey for me the best part of
this particular story is
everything that happened up until the
point they meet polymorph in the
coliseum which was wonderful to see and
his transformation into the tortoise was
fittingly hilarious too
however unfortunately this isn't where
the ending concludes either when diavolo
is defeated by not giorno but instead
his stand gold experience
we are shown something of a miniark that
takes place
over two episodes wherein we see a
flashback showing what bruno and mista
did right before meeting giorno in
person towards the beginning of the
story this was one of the strangest
decisions made
narratively in my opinion right as the
climax hits we are dragged back in time
to the beginning of the story for what
feels like an ova with optional content
killing what little hype and expectation
i had during the occasion
in favor of showing me a story about
fate told through a boulder with
separation anxiety
all before calling back to the main
story where everyone just sort of says
goodbye
and good job to each other and walks off
before once again cutting to the future
with
giorno as a mob boss for a few seconds
what
happened to the people of naples he
wanted to help what happened to what
bruno wanted to achieve for his town
what happened to giorno's goal and are
we meant to just accept that everything
is fine and that he took care of it
off-screen
these are the motivating factors that
caused us to get behind these characters
in the first place
showing what the character has achieved
is part of the payoff it's the goal of
the entire story this is like watching
ash ketchum travel far and wide to
become the pokemon league champion only
for the writers to cut that part out
this would be like watching luffy have
the heartfelt confrontation with nami
during arlen park
only for them to cut out the gang
fighting arlong and flash to the
aftermath for three or four
seconds having spent months covering the
story one thing i've become accustomed
to
has been how these stories like to bask
in the spoils of their win
and the extravagant means with which
they like to conclude the final fights
but moreover i like how the main
characters play a role in that finish
but giorno really doesn't get to do much
of anything other than to facilitate the
existence of
gold experiences change i've spent a
long time talking about these hang-ups
i've had because i wanted to make
perfectly clear that these issues i have
are aspects of the story i've attempted
to think through i've no issue with this
being someone's favorite ending and i've
been diligent
in saying that these are just my own
personal opinions but by the time i
reached the ending of the story i was
completely convinced that this wasn't so
much an act but more so
the story of how jorno became who he is
or should i say the story about how
giorno
looked like he was the one who was going
to achieve something only for gold
experience to actually be the one to do
that instead
maybe gold experience should be the mob
boss now in other words
this story didn't feel like it was in
service of its own narrative but instead
it felt like it was in service of the
next and
when it comes to the conclusion of a
particular arc i don't care about the
next one i care about what we've built
up to here and now and for me golden
wind didn't deliver
anything that i wanted personally now
okay that's a lot of negativity
with all of that said however 95 of this
story is by far
my favorite arc in the story with
characters that felt
fun and relatable i'm still a firm
believer that bruno mister and naranja
are
the best characters in the story heck
the globe diavolo got in the second half
made him one of the more interesting
characters too
which brings me to this moment it's time
for the tier list over the last eight
videos and two months i have reviewed
all five currently released and
localized arcs
of hirohiko araki's jojo's bizarre
adventure an anthology of stories
following primarily the bloodlines of
the joe stars and in the case of the
most recent arc
dio brando however seeing as this will
be my last review
i make on jojo until part six gets
translated i will
right here and now present you all with
my tier list for my favorite jojo's
and my favorite jojo ops alright so
right off the bat i'm gonna need to
destroy
everything from d tier and below
everything on this list i at the very
least
enjoyed particularly with the music i
even had all of these tracks playing
while i worked on this video and yes
i know all of the lyrics see tier
jonathan joestar
so working our way up starting with the
jojo that initiated this whole journey
we have the og himself
jonathan joster as the original jojo he
sort of sets the standard and
to be frank had you approached me before
i began this review and told me i would
end up
liking jonathan i never would have
believed you while not being very
interesting in terms of personality i
found his virtuous death both
tragic and shocking made all the more
emotional in later installments
particularly in their ops
but i'll get to that later next up
traitor's requiem
it's funny how the first jojo and the
last song from part 5
are opening up this list traitor's
requiem is a somewhat understated song
and one that i truthfully almost forgot
to include on this list maybe i'd rank
it higher if it had more time to grow on
me however
as the second op from golden wind it'll
have to stand alongside jonathan as the
bar
set for this series chase coming in as a
sea tier entrant is
chase from diamond is unbreakable as the
middle child of the three diamond is
unbreakable ops
it didn't really have much narratively
to play with from a visual perspective
and musically i think this is probably
one of the songs i listen to the least
with that said i still know all of the
lyrics and i do love it
b-tier giorno giovanna and with that we
arrive at the tier labeled bee
and i get a sinking feeling people are
going to be really upset that i've
decided to place jorno here
as you've seen in this and the last
review covering the events of part 5 i
am a massive fan of what it managed to
achieve in captivating me but also
in demonstrating how much better araki
managed to get as a writer during his
time
working on jojo with all of that said
due to the ensemble nature of this story
and the lack of screen time
journal ultimately received i didn't
really have that much of a chance to
form much of a bond with him as a
character there are plenty of instances
throughout enduring the story where i
really enjoyed him as a character
however it wasn't enough to give him an
edge over the other jojo's on this tier
list for me
fighting gold on the other hand i have
no idea as to whether or not placing
fighting gold on the b
tier is a controversial take or not
seeing this song here shouldn't be an
indication of anything other than the
quality and high standard all of the
other tracks have set
but yeah i really like this song just
not as much as i've come to expect from
jojo
it could have something to do with the
chorus but who knows bloody stream
like i said i had no idea if the
previous one was a controversial take
i do however know for a fact that this
one will be controversial
bloody stream i adore the song and i
love how cool and smooth the lead
singer's vocals are
i have no idea if this song's proximity
to other tracks in the series played a
role or whether or not
it's much more subdued arrangement when
compared with the others played into its
position here
i just never really connected with the
song in the same intense way i did with
all the others that came after on this
list
as b tier goes i'd say this is the
strongest contender for a tier but
not quite i had to draw the line
somewhere in the sand and
bloody stream just didn't make the cut
for me personally
a tier crazy noisy bizarre town i'm a
massive fan of tracks that capture the
essence and tone of their respective
stories
and if i'm being perfectly honest crazy
noisy bizarre town sets the standard in
that department catchy upbeat with
fittingly bizarre visuals featured over
the quaint little town the story is
based within
this is perhaps more than any other an
earworm i'll never shake
and you know what i'm not even mad
josuke hikashikata
something i've noticed in my reading
through of jojo's bizarre adventure is
that the main characters seem to take
more and more of a backseat role from
joseph onwards and
while josuke didn't get the giorno
treatment in that he had to totally
share with all of the other side
characters
equally i felt like i could have done
with more screen time with josuke there
really aren't too many scenes in that
story where the audience gets to spend
some one-on-one time with josuke
and i think that probably played a role
into my bonding with the character
i feel like josuke deserves to be on the
s tier but for some reason i felt like
after the arc finished there was
still so much i wanted to know and learn
about josuke i wanted more
which i suppose is a good thing if not
for the fact that i expected more
regardless from what i did see i saw a
subtly emotional light-hearted and
relaxed jojo that i
thoroughly enjoyed from start to finish
and for a long time was in the running
for my all-time
favorite jojo kujo jotaro unlike josuke
whom i liked from the outset jodoro was
very much a character that took time to
grow on me initially my exposure to him
via the anime many many years ago
created a feeling
of boredom surrounding the character
however through the manga i sincerely
thought a lot more subtle emotional cues
shine through
that coupled with some wonderfully timed
straight face gags and some
truly badass scenes with him journal
climbs out of the expectations i had and
into the extremely entertaining a-tier
great days of all the tracks on this
list this is the one that surprised me
the most by how much i love it capping
off the last spot on
a tier is diamond is unbreakable's op
great days
this track managed to reach this high
spot despite me only knowing about it
for the last few weeks
which i mean speaks volumes about how
much i like and listen to this
song it's not as punchy as some of the
other tracks in s tier but as far as the
softer jojo tracks go this one is my
absolute favorite crazy noisy bizarre
town is awesome
but i'd sincerely think i enjoyed this
one just that little bit more
and now the time you've all been waiting
for time for the s
tier first up sono chi no kyoku
kicking things off and setting the
standard from this point on is the last
op of part three
sonochino unlike many of the other ops
this one in particular feels as though
it's mirroring the story starting
ominously it builds to an impactful
moment following the visuals of the
stardust crusaders making their way to
dio and man when they do eventually get
to dio this op
features a revised do edit mirroring the
story perfectly and giving further
context to the original version it's
catchy
it's informed by the story and while i
was reading along this track
really got me hyped stand proud
while i know a lot of people prefer
sonochino kyoku over
proud this track marked the instance
that this series really and truly hooked
me on a narrative level before hearing
this track i knew i loved the music and
i knew i could really get into certain
characters but
what this op did for me was bring to the
forefront of my mind that this story was
more than just a third
largely disconnected plot but something
that we've been building towards
for years with jonathan's closing eyes
joseph as a young man turning around
and jottero standing and facing forward
in that split second of the op
it reminded me that this arc will be the
culmination of everything that came
before it and in a weird way
was sort of nostalgic to me and on top
of that this track also gave me a new
appreciation for
jonathan joestar and slaps so damn hard
which
never hurts joseph joster finally
here he is my favorite jojo joseph
joster
standing proud and ester this character
captures pretty much everything i like
in a character he's active
not too serious intelligent and with a
hidden kindness that he doesn't like to
flaunt all that often
within my infamous watch through all
those years ago that ended with me not
liking the series at all there were two
things that i liked and one of them was
joseph joster in addition to that i
think my love forum is aided by way of
him being present and taking part
in three separate arcs of jojo but for
me
nothing will be battle tendency joseph
he's snarky he's brilliant and he's
hot as and now it's time to share with
you all my favorite op
from jojo sono chi no sadame
this song is based long before i ever
gave this series another shot back in
the days i was convinced i didn't like
jojo
i still had sonochino sadame unabashedly
blasting in the speakers of my car with
the windows open
screaming the lyrics and i'm not just
talking about the op i'm talking about
the full version too
wearing the singer with every passing
chorus bellows a more emphatic and long
jo joe than the last with the final jojo
exclamation lasting
eight seconds that's awesome and for me
it's the series best track
by far and that's my tier list i have a
list of my favorite jojo parts too but
i'll be posting them to my twitter
instead if you want to see that list
check me out at totally not mark while
this definitely won't be the last video
i'll review in the jojo story
it is the last review alright for quite
a while at least until the next act gets
officially translated i think it's such
an amazing thing getting to experience
these stories alongside the fans that
adore it and
for that i am truly grateful and
appreciative for the position that i'm
in and for the support that you've all
given me i'd like to also extend a
special thank you to anime aj for
filling in as a guest editor for this
series
i think he did an amazing job and i
can't wait to work with him in the
future on other projects
however next week it's back to business
as usual for the month of march with
some dragon ball
and maybe some one piece content however
during the month of april
i begin a new series in hunter hunter
i've been waiting to start this story
for ages and i've been hearing
so much about it but until then i've
been toying that mark thank you all once
again so much for the support you've
shown over the last two months and i
can't wait to see you all
on the next adventure
you